[Music]
if anybody knows how to start a party
it's my brother andrew
or should i say legit conductor
it's fine it's so cute it's so good no
mom if anybody sees that i'm going to
get put on a watch list
i can't believe college is over you have
a job now we're not allowed to talk
about jobs at the batman party so you
either don't have a job or you have a
bad job how much does a party starter
get paid i wonder
i have a bad job yeah
honey i'm not just saying this because
i'm your mother i feel like you're way
ahead of the game
[Music]
who's that that's a mom and a kid
do you two dance we're not feeling that
right now how about i bet you 300 i can
get her on the dance floor i will give
you a thousand dollars
[Music]
she really likes you i really like her
tonight is the night that you and lola
danced your booties off
oh i don't know how to moonwalk
do you think he would be a good sitter
for you i do not do well with sitters
but i think it might be a bit different
with andrew
do you want to meet my hamster
yeah
i want to thank you for being so kind to
lola easiest thing in the world i'm
having more fun now than i did the whole
night
[Music]
do you have a husband i have a fiance i
hear you're a great party starter i hear
you're a great professional lawyer
must figure out after college
[Music]
giving your heart to somebody is the
most
perplexing thing
you can't just decide that you love
somebody yes you can no you can't yes
you can
we don't need you to babysit anymore why
lots of
are you reasons right now son everything
is just submits
growing up is hard
is he your soul mate do you believe in
soulmates i think we all have a ton of
soul mates how many soul mates for you
like four how many do you have like
twelve hundred
[Music]
you